little [ __ ] what movie trailer guys
says it he totally sounds like it I
think he slipped up so Little Fockers is
part three of the Meet the Parents
trilogy I guess it's a trilogy now now
10 years ago Meet the Parents was huge
and it was funny and relatable and even
sparked a nationwide fetish with dads
hook and their daughters dudes up to
polygraphs and 10 years later alright so
after DeNiro didn't trust Gaylord Focker
dating his daughter he then didn't trust
him marrying his daughter and now he
still doesn't trust him being the
married father of her children the first
time was funny the second time felt like
recycled jokes the third time it's just
annoying
you know when American Wedding came out
and you were like yeah it's funny but
it's time to hang up the Hat on this
Little Fockers makes American Wedding
look like a comedic masterpiece there
were a couple of funny moments in this
movie but it really shocked me how often
I did not laugh and it's a bummer cuz
Meet the Parents was funny but it's just
more I'm watching you [ __ ]
yep ten years later I'm still butting my
business into your marriage a couple of
laughs I'll strike that chuckles but
Jessica Alba is hot like really hot
other than that same ol [ __ ] not done as
well ten years later it just drives me
up the wall
and I noticed DeNiro never actually
apologizes he never says I am sorry in
fact I was a dick I will trust you now
but even if he did he'd take it back in
the next movie so what's the point
although I just don't think there should
be or will be a next movie funniest part
in this movie the end credits and I
don't mean that like oh the best parts
the end credits cuz the movies over had
no I mean during the end credits footage
is still playing and it's actually
really funny so because of the end
credits the rating for this movie
actually moved up to it's okay but you
won't remember it and T - end credits at
the end of this movie I was just
thinking man True Grit
in a world of nine to ten dollars a
ticket don't bother but if you liked
what you seen here and you want to see
more than click right here to see more
[Music]